[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm link and I'm
red this week at the round table of dim
lighting yeah we're back at the round
table of dim lighting yeah we're gonna
be talking about what really happened at
mythicon
yeah this is if there's a secret that
we've been holding on to there's not
really well I think there's a
sensational introduction I mean there's
definitely some behind the scenes oh
yeah like I mean there's things that we
haven't talked about about our
experience that you know I think it's
good to just
put it put it down put down our uh
experience to to tape or whatever type
of digital ones and zeros we record
things to for posterity and because it's
very fresh right now so fresh just got
back home
just a couple of days ago the wounds are
still open
um so the the experience is very very
fresh on our minds and in our hearts I
would say that the the general feeling
right now but both the general feeling
while we were at mythicon and then as
mythicon was coming to a close and in
these days after is that it was a
success like we're feeling really good
about
uh the way that the mythical beasts
responded to it the the work that the
mythical crew put into it I mean the
thing that we said all along is that if
we can create a positive experience for
the majority of people who are there
then we have succeeded because when you
go out and try to do something for the
first time that has a convention before
release by us yeah and dumb you know
something like this specifically hasn't
been done in the in created um uh this
sort of uh more Boutique event or
whatever you want to call it at a place
that was at a convention immersive
um today
experience we're feeling good I yeah I'm
feeling good that doesn't mean that
there that there weren't things that
went wrong and there weren't things that
uh could have been done better and
there's not constructive criticism
floating around uh which we can talk a
little bit about but yeah I'm
I mean my first thing was
nobody died was maimed or taken away on
a stretcher like honestly yeah so I was
just so glad because like these
conventions have a reputation for like
really going south you know uh
documentaries made about them well as
the as the days
approached I mean that's I mean that is
one of the things I wanted to talk about
was just the way that
we were feeling about things as the date
was approaching right and I'll I'll say
I also want to talk about like
we will talk about what what does this
mean for the future of mythicon what are
our plans what do we know we know some
things already so we can talk about that
yeah so yeah you see you you can go back
to your feelings now I I will say
ultimately
before we start stepping through it I I
kind of feel like I'm basking in the
Afterglow of uh a milestone career
moment like just being able to
experience mythicon was
extremely positive for me personally and
I'm just so grateful that we have
a relationship with the mythical Beast
such that like we can all get excited
about creating something like this and
and it was really special like there
were a number of points where I was like
I think this is the peak for me this is
my favorite thing about mythicon and
that happened probably five times well
the way I described it
on Twitter uh I guess on Sunday like
right you know or Monday right after it
was over
it represented a culmination of
this relationship that we've been
building for for many years I I think
that that is that's why I'm taking away
despite some of the things that were
like lessons learned that we will take
into the future which we were fully
expecting is like you do something for
the first time you're like oh this this
and that these are things that we would
change these are things that we would do
differently you go into a new Venture
expecting to learn those lessons
but the thing that I was really hoping
would be the core experience of the
event would be
that this relationship that we've been
building with the mythical beast and for
some that's a
over 10-year relationship for some
that's a 10-week relationship and
everything in between that it would feel
somewhere like 16 years that
um the relationship that had been
building and being had been cultivated
was
being expressed almost in the way that
if you think about
you've got uh somebody you have a long
distance and I don't want to make this
it's not like a romantic thing but a
friendship let's just say you meet
somebody pen pal and actually this is
the case with a lot of people that we
ended up talking to in the meet and
greet and then in the brunch we got to
interact a total of eight hours
over the course of two days
two and a half days we ended up having I
don't know if you thought about it like
this eight hours of direct interaction
with mythical beasts like one on one one
on two one on Three
because when you when you count your
James and the shame set no I'm just
counting me I know if you count if you
count if you count James in the shame
and you're Youjizz and uh then I'm
talking that's ten hours I'm saying yeah
a two hour meet and greet on Friday two
hour meet and greet on Saturday and then
a four hour brunch on Sunday I don't
know if you realize we were there from
10 o'clock to two o'clock
interacting with people individually
going around going around to each table
like it was a wedding reception yeah and
in one sense it was emotionally draining
because to have uh sometimes intense
interactions with people who are you
know they've got a lot of things that
they've been feeling and thinking for
years that now they have an opportunity
to tell you but for the most part
including those things it was it was
ultimately very energizing and I agree
yeah it's it's like you've got this pen
pal that you've been talking to for
years and who never writes you back but
you know they're reading all of them
yeah and they might post things and then
the relationship is kind of
consummated don't do it in person and
that's the funny thing is we kept seeing
people who were like yeah I've been this
is a mythical Beast that I that I have a
friendship with and now we've been
hanging out all weekend there's that
that was happening which was beautiful
and which is why we wanted to do it in
person and bring people together but
then there were the interactions that we
could have and not just with us but with
everybody got to interact with the crew
both in a meet and greet setting but
also just because it was this little
town and I think that that was that was
the peak of it for me was seeing that
this relationship that has been building
for so long can kind of be expressed in
a way that you can only do in person and
yeah when you describe it as like a
boutique immersive experience that was
what was
it so exciting to see come together
because that was part of our original
idea you know it could have been two
years ago right when we first hatched
the idea of of mythicon in the throes of
the pandemic and lockdown uh in our
opening speech from the rooftop where
man I could have fallen off of that roof
yeah well the one instruction that was
given to link and this is there's gonna
be a number of things like this that
come up I'm sure but the one instruction
that was given to the link at least five
times was when you step out on this roof
there will be a little there will be a
rug that's big enough for the two of you
to stand on don't step off of that
because at that moment you'll be on just
like a tin roof that may have
condensation on it it's not you know it
could be slippery and literally the
first thing you did was step off of the
rug well I took a step and then I took a
second step and then I was looking at
all the people down there and then I
looked down at my foot and I really I
remembered I'm supposed to stay on the
rug and when I looked down at my second
step that foot that was out there I was
like there's no where there's no rug at
all where's the rug and I realized I had
already stepped over the rug yeah it was
the first thing because there's only
there's only one step of the road I've I
pictured a rug going from the window
that we stepped out of onto that rooftop
like it's like a red carpet going right
to the edge well that's what you would
picture and then when I looked down I I
I was looking all around for the rug
then I looked behind me and saw the rug
and I saw you standing on it if you had
I took a step if you had slipped off and
like I had to like go out there and like
hold you up first of all everyone who
would have thought no they wouldn't have
thought that it was planned they would
have known because the all the other
thing that was should have done that the
other thing that was planned a little
behind the scenes here is that we were
also told multiple times but
unfortunately we weren't told right
before we did it that uh someone was
planning a proposal and that are really
our only job was to recognize this guy
welcome everybody to mythicon cover some
Logistics that actually we didn't even
need to cover because they were covered
elsewhere and then just throw it over to
this guy Wesley was his name
weatherholtz Wesley weatherholtz still
is a great name
throw it over to Wesley and then Wesley
would take it from there he was like in
a light you know like there was like
basically like he was under a light so
everybody could see him he was waiting
he was waiting our entire speech and our
other job I will say was to give a
kick-ass welcome speech after cotton
candy Randy introduced us and I think we
delivered man yeah we have one
microphone we had to share it we didn't
get in a fight
almost I didn't go too off the rails
yeah I didn't we wore a pink hat that
was good I found the pink hat up there
in the Attic but yeah he was waiting for
our Kick-Ass speeches to be done and you
know he just you know just imagine you
you're going to propose like I was so
nervous when I was going to propose and
I did it two weeks early by accident you
know this guy was like I'm about to do
it all I got to do is say my name and
then we go through the whole speech and
then we're like wrapping things up and
then we like say tata for now and we go
back in and he's just standing there I'm
feeling so bad I feel so bad for him
like what we put in through by accident
we just forgot and the moment we duck
our heads back into the door
Jenna's like
The Proposal get back out so we like
turn around before everybody disperses
it was like that quick no one started
moving but then you started talking into
the microphone which had been cut off
and the microphone was off the music
people are dispersing now we're yelling
don't leave don't leave please don't
leave
and that's I so we ended up handing it
over to him I did say at that moment do
not let this be indicative of how
mythicons are going to go because
thankfully we're actually not in charge
of the details like this is one of the
things that we were supposed to remember
but our team is better at remembering
those kinds of details I don't want to
dog anybody but it kind of was
indicative of mythicon we'll get into
that in a few ways that like some things
don't go exactly as planned and you have
to roll with it and make the best of it
but back to what I was saying when I was
given this speech what I told them there
that I was saying again here is that
like
we hatched mythicon
in the throes of the pandemic we missed
that interaction with fans you know we
had two years of on and off touring and
we were like let's let's do an event
let's let's make something that is an
experience and let's we need to make it
something that is not just called a
convention and it's not just where
people show up to see us do a show alone
or just watch uh watch people record
their podcast like I just was kind of we
were immediately averse to just creating
what we had already experienced at
VidCon honestly but only for mythical
beasts we wanted to do something that
was
a holistic experience and we thought the
venue would have a lot to do with that
um
and it turns out we were taking a lot of
risks when we
when we picked a venue that was outdoors
and a lot of those things but like we we
did it because it was so charming and
unlike any other place you could go and
once you showed up there
I mean it was kind of like being at a
very preliminary version of Disney if it
was just us you know like on like a
small primordial scale but that was kind
of the idea so when fans actually a
couple of fans was like this is kind of
like a Disney Experience because
we try to the team tried to think of all
the details of uh along the way and
you know if you read the fine print on
things you would see there were jokes on
them you know that's kind of an example
of you know yes this sign says do not
enter this particular building but then
it also makes a joke about that I can't
remember the jokes but like a lot of
them had to do with you not being
allowed in the book right which sounds
very funny yes yes to that and I think
that incidentally
um most of the challenges and Lessons
Learned are related to the fact that we
chose such a
specific venue that was isolated that
required shuttling people to it that
you're all your food options and
everything you're there right you're
kind of isolated on this island we made
a decision because we were going for
this more memorable unique experience
that created challenges that obviously
we knew this going in but challenges
that you wouldn't have if you were at a
Convention Center where you've got your
hotel Center is designed to have a
convention at it and transportation to a
Convention Center a lot of times is just
walking from your hotel room which is
somewhere if you want other options for
for things to do you can just step right
out and go to things in a metro area
that kind of thing so we understand that
those are things that created challenges
but a Convention Center is a Convention
Center I'm not saying that if we if we
you know do this again it won't be at a
place that can accommodate those kinds
of things which I guess this is a good
time to go ahead and talk about the fact
that
even we were planning on this even
before mythicon just so you know uh that
we had made a decision in the months
leading up to mythicon 2022 that we were
not going to do a mythicon 2023 because
we wanted more than 12 months in order
to learn the lessons that we learned in
22 and be able to apply them in 23
because there's things like selecting a
location
taking into account all the the amount
of the work that our team did and how do
you divide that between the mythical
team and then we worked with on location
a great company that does the festivals
so in order to give ourselves more
runway for Lessons Learned and planning
and moving forward we're just going to
go ahead and tell you that there's not a
mythicon 23 we already knew that going
in
uh but it's worth mentioning now as
we're as we're talking about this again
because if we if we do it again or when
we do this again we want it to be done
um even better and be a step up from
where we started yeah so at this point
kind of everything's on the table in
terms of like how we follow up mythagon
2022 with something that the earliest it
would be would be 2024. right
um in terms of how we do it
um
but I would I just really I I just
consider the whole thing a success you
know I know that
you know it wasn't about the money you
know I'll also be honest about that you
know uh it's we we you know we didn't
make money I'm just you know well I
think
I I think we broke even I don't think we
broke even oh okay well I'm gonna think
that because it makes we're still we're
still working through we're still
working through the finances uh but as
of right now all indications are that we
paid
we paid to make meant to God happen
which again I'm just I'm over here
fixing my hair because I don't I don't
want to hear well no no but again we we
was worth it it was totally worth it but
also it wasn't a surprise
every single Festival that I've ever
heard of
cost the people who threw the festival
money the first time they did it and
that's what we we went in saying listen
this is not going to be a money-making
venture maybe one day it will be but
this is not and people are probably
thinking
man for all them for the money I pay for
my ticket yeah well they still didn't
make any money but they're like yeah
it's okay that's all part of it there
were lots of comments going around about
another money grab by mythical which
again it's not the kind of thing we're
going to come out and say guys listen
we're gonna we are paying to do this uh
but that is the fact is that it was not
a money grab there's lots of ways that
we could do a money grab if we were if
we if we chose to
um but it was starting to it was
beginning something just like in the
book of mythicality when we talk about
pick a direction and go just start doing
something we have a tendency and listen
we do a lot of things that don't work
because we do a lot of things and if you
do a lot of things you're going to do a
lot of things that don't work and we
knew going into this that it's very
unlikely unless we score like a us again
because like the you know we we called
liquid death a sponsor they were a
sponsor in that they gave us the water
but which was huge we didn't get any
money uh we would have to get a number
of sponsors and this is just so it's the
festival world where we learned is is an
interesting thing and and so now that
we've done it and it was a positive
experience for the majority of people
who were there next time maybe you can
begin to introduce those kinds of things
that help support it financially in a
way that it becomes a money-making
Venture which again which we would we
would want it to be because we don't
want to pay out of our own pockets and
lose money every time we do something
like this regardless of how special it
was but it's totally totally fine to for
that to be the case in the first one yes
and
just take a quick aside here speaking of
things that were not charging mythical
Beasts for but that are amazing and
edifying experiences
I want to invite you to go over to
sport.com
it's the website that we created where
all of our taste tests of anything you
can buy in the grocery store are
reflected in ranking form and In
Articles and if there's like new types
of snacks or grocery store items that
you can try
our team has tried it at sport and
they're writing about it so you can be
exposed to what's the best thing to buy
and what's the new fun things to buy go
to sport.com you don't have to pay a
dime
oh you just came with a little jingle
it's free I never got back to talking
about how I was feeling in the days uh
yeah coaching but
I gotta say
with every year that passes I feel like
both of us get better at
just dealing with
increasing amounts of pressure to
perform or for something to be pulled
off and eventually you just get to this
point where you're like there's I mean
doing everything I can to make this
everything that it can be and everything
that we want it to be but there's a
number of things that are outside of our
control and just you know the larger the
mythical gets and the and the more
things that we try
the more kind of impervious you get to
just stepping into another experience
that you feel completely unqualified for
I feel like every single year I'm just
doing something else that I feel
unqualified for my life has almost
become doing things that I feel
unqualified for and so I've actually
gotten better oh yeah at not being
nervous about things definitely but
there was a lot of I think hidden stress
that was popping up in certain ways that
I wasn't you know I was trying to talk
about them in therapy there were things
like and I know this is the case for
both of us in addition to mythicon
and everything else that we continue
have continually have going on just you
know running mythical and everything
else that we're doing
there was these special sort of
um inaugural events in their own right
of me performing as James and the shame
and you making your DJ debut and and
doing the dance party kind of what we
were calling the bookends of mythicon of
me kind of opening things up on night
one and you closing things down on night
two
that I was very I was very nervous about
because
that you know while I have performed
music in front of crowds for years I've
never done music like that and I was
performing my whole album which I'd
never performed live for anyone and
Jesse was joining me and Jesse was super
nervous because she hasn't been in front
of an audience in a very long time right
so there it was the new thing that took
a lot of your focus you know because it
was
that was a big deal you know and it had
yet you had no you hadn't done it before
yeah I definitely felt that way about
the DJ set I you know what I have so
much that I want to talk about about my
DJ Premiere and some things that
happened afterward that I haven't told
you about like there's so much that
people are asking how did I come up with
the name uh
and like the entire experience was so
surreal like the costume every
everything that went into it it went
into the Persona I'd love to just table
that until like next episode because I
have so much that I want to unpack until
you can just have a Elkhound a snuggle
baby unpacking epis episode like yeah
that sounds like a plan I have so much
and I want
there's so much I want to hear from you
that I haven't asked you about like your
vantage point of the whole thing is
quite Advantage
so uh next episode we'll we'll talk
about the Elkhound snuggle baby of it
all but yeah I was talking to Jesse
about I was like you know what I can I
can help you be less nervous because
like you're kind of doing something that
I have a point of reference for you know
in terms of like singing with Rhett
showing up for sound check performing
songs that you rarely perform and then
uh we didn't get to talk until we were
like on the way to the airport together
and she's like where is all this advice
you're going to give me and I thought I
had some really good advice I was like
first of all you're gonna be nervous
like I don't get nervous about a lot of
things the point you were making earlier
because
when you just have to do something a lot
to get to a point where you're not
nervous about it like to to do something
big and that you've never done before in
front of a crowd or maybe for you
listening it's something you're taking
your own risk it might not be crowd
oriented but it's something that you're
like putting yourself out there you're
going out of your comfort zone
absolutely you're going to be nervous
and you that's going to keep happening
until you do it so much that you
actually start you need to look for
something else to make you nervous
that's the great thing about James and
the shame for you and the DJ set for me
and mythicon was
a lot of my emotional energy was geared
towards those things because they were
so new so I just you know I was like yes
you're going to feel nervous it's
totally it's part of this it's part of
it trying to find a way to have some fun
in the moment is is kind of like a North
star it may not happen
but I was like
the only practical advice I can give you
is when you're singing when you go up
there and you sing for the sound check
don't worry about what any crew or
anybody thinks like you're not trying to
sound good for anybody so don't even
worry about that I used to be fixated on
that like let's write a song called the
soundcheck song so that we can not seem
so stupid out there for sound check
that's how self-conscious I used to be
about sound checks I was like don't
worry about that this is about you
getting comfortable and for me when I
sing with Rhett and I'm on a mic and in
a place that I don't know what it sounds
like and
I sing the Melody I sing in unison
before I break into any Harmony just so
I can tell and then I was like I thought
this was like gonna be the best advice
ever and she's like yeah that's not
gonna work for me like that's that would
totally mess me up I would totally lose
my Harmony life well because like me
because she is not a typical Harmony
singer
um
she has a tendency to begin singing The
Melody the way that she screws up is by
singing The Melody by accident well
that's a lot worse than going flat
anyway so it was that was a big moment
so just to go to that I mean that was
that was the first night we did the
welcome I think there's a lot of things
packed up in this that kind of speak to
mythicon broadly so yeah um so the first
thing we did
when we got there on Thursday so we
arrived on Wednesday night uh but then
Thursday
mid-morning we show up at Star Hill
Ranch is where we had it and what we
knew was that rain first of all it had
rained on Monday pretty significantly
uh and it was supposed to rain on Friday
morning so this everybody's arriving at
3 P.M on Friday
the first now Paisley nothing's paved
here it's it's a ranch yeah everything's
dirt there's gravel and there's dirt but
so Paisley kind of gives us the tour of
the stuff that had already been set up
there's still a lot of things that were
coming together you know on that day
because these people are getting there
setting everything up it kind of takes
us through these are all these little
there's basically houses and structures
buildings all along this thorough fair
and each one had been themed in a
certain way was you know here's the
mythical movie house where they're
constantly running
you know sets different programming
about there's the music the mythical
Museum which was awesome which was super
cool to attention to detail for that was
awesome kind of baked into the meet and
greet hall there's the merchandise area
there's the the VR Saloon there's a VR
experience where you can like see an
accurate representation of the entire
GMM set and pick up everything and like
hear us talking in your ear about
everything that you're interacting with
and darts that you're throwing yeah so
so we took a tour of all that getting
increasingly excited then we go down to
the main there's a barber shop there's a
barbershop their hair cut their head
shaved their beard trim okay there was a
there was a a tattoo parlor and we did
not anticipate the literal several
hundred people who wanted tattoos
waiting for hours we actually had to
people
turned away because
it's one of those things that we had it
in mind from the beginning we want to
offer people tattoos we want people to
get tattoos at mythicon
and
we're like everybody wanted what
percentage of like 2 300 people would
want to get tattoos right apparently 50
more than you would think yeah so anyway
so we're getting excited about it but
then we go down to the main stage area
which is an Amphitheater sort of you
know outdoor Amphitheater sort of grassy
area but the first thing we kind of
notice is that there's a lot of mud
amongst this grass
I don't know the logistical history of
exactly how we got to this point but we
were kind of alarmed and they were
bringing in like gravel like you know
crushed granite and stuff and they're
like trucks coming in and the guy who
owns the place is like in a you know
Bobcat a bobcat like moving stuff around
and we're like okay
um this is a little disconcerting
they're like well we're gonna it's gonna
rain on Friday we're gonna you know
we're gonna cover the whole thing with
plastic baseball field Style
but getting a little nervous about that
because that was where three very
important things were happening the
first night games in the shame
performance the live ear biscuit that we
were going to do uh on Saturday morning
and then of course the main stage show
on Saturday night and for each thing
there was like a separate State
presentation that we had prepared right
so that we weren't stealing the Thunder
from our like main performance on
Saturday night and it allowed everybody
to sit down in the amphitheater and like
lounge and it was kind of like our
vision was like picnic style hang out a
lot of space
and and even monitor setup I think so it
was like
it went from that like okay we're just
trying to keep this thing as dry as
possible and there's no that we were
like they know you know I'm a civil
engineer by degree and at least by
training it for a couple of years in
drainage
was drainage and Grading and sort of you
know pervious you know permeable
surfaces that was my specialty so this
is your fault so I actually the first
thing I said was this is not I don't
feel great about this I don't feel great
about this being okay by Friday the
first thing I said when I showed up on
Thursday but you weren't wearing a hard
hat
so I
um and I think this is really what
represents we talked about this on stage
at the show uh and also at the at the
Jameson shame show
foreign
this sort of capture our rehearsal on
Thursday night I think is a perfect
encapsulation of what mythical is and
what mythicality is from a creative
perspective because
Jesse and I get up there to sing these
songs for the first time live and also
for the first time on an amplified
system which you know there's a
difference between sitting down in your
living room like Jesse and I've been
practicing these songs it is strange
that's what I was trying to tell her and
we were hoping that we would have time
to maybe play a show somewhere in LA on
like an amplified system you know of
course we don't have time for that so
the day approaches it's like here we go
so the first thing I notice as I start
singing into this giant sound system
that's being broadcast through the whole
place is that I sound horrible that's
the first thing you think because your
ear has to
tune into the way that everything is
happening in the monitors in the PA
so you practice you you did that for an
hour you played the whole album and I
played
the songs Jesse performed on three songs
we played those songs at least three
times each yeah until the until the
point where I'm like okay I feel good
so Jesse leaves and then
you walk out of a building and come down
and without like changing clothes or
anything we immediately go into the main
stage show rehearsal and at that point
is when you can kind of see like these
confused looks on people's faces because
here I'm up there playing these serious
country songs about religious
deconstruction
which is so out of the blue
and then all of a sudden and all the
crew and people who were just hired to
make everything happen they don't know
what they're there for it's like okay I
can understand this and then the next
thing is a country artist another guy
shows up and we're suddenly riding on a
double bicycle rehearsing our route up
onto stage right at which point we wrap
everything's okay cause I'm on vacation
and I at that point you see people
leaning over and talking to each other
and actually after that that rehearsal
that night I walked past that guy and he
was trying to explain what was going on
and I heard little bits and pieces like
they yeah they they do YouTube and
they've got fans that are showing up
here
yeah and so but the fact that other than
that I can't help you and then if they
stuck around for the Elkhound snuggle
baby reveal it's just the same guy that
you were sawing now in this outfit doing
this
yeah but the thing I told the crowd at
the James and the shame show and maybe
at the main show
that's the beauty of mythicality that's
the beauty of of of mythical well we're
honored under rituals because you're
never No One's Gonna Get to everyone who
was there
it makes complete sense that there's
this guy and his wife singing These
serious country songs and then that are
making people weep yeah oh and listen
I'll tell you about how I try I try I
got through that set without crying in a
moment but then then he and this other
guy are doing this crazy show where they
summon an alien and we'll get into that
and then it follows up with the other
guy
who joined him on stage is now in this
outfit
uh that I'll let you describe in a later
point and thank you he calls himself
Elkhound snuggle baby and he's DJing a
party
for to any Outsider it makes no sense at
all
but to a mythical Beast it's like yeah
of course this is this completely makes
sense it all fits together in this world
and I love the fact that those people
get it and that's why we did it because
they do get it and that's what I told
Jesse I said the reason you shouldn't be
nervous
is because
this audience will be the warmest
audience and most supportive audience
that you could possibly imagine so much
so that when she she comes out
they go nuts when she comes out and she
started she was trying not to cry she
was you could see it she was like trying
not to cry and I was like I was thinking
I told you I told you you had nothing to
worry about now it's impossible to tell
somebody to knock because you started
singing
no she sounded great
um let me tell you man so that was
just to talk briefly about that we can
move on well the there was just the one
part of the story you can't leave out is
that we're driving to the venue the
Friday morning
to then like oh get ready for the whole
thing yeah and we get a phone call
from Stevie who's like I'm already here
we're moving nothing is on the
amphitheater stage nothing except for
your main show no beer biscuits no James
in the shame tonight
we're moving it all to the Big Ten
because we have to do everything we can
to try to preserve the grounds so that
people can see your main show there so
all that practice you did and
acclimation you got to that sound system
forget all of that because now James and
the shame is performing in the big tent
and the big tent the reason James and
the shame in your biscuits were not
originally scheduled for the big tent is
because they're not big enough for the
amount of people that we anticipated
being at those two events right
so we made the best of it but everybody
had to stand that wasn't it wasn't ideal
from from my life you know everybody
made the best of it from my perspective
I didn't I I didn't let it affect me uh
because I was like of course of course
I'm gonna have to I can't explain it all
that time getting ready on this
particular sound system and now we've
got to go do a sound check a short sound
check this completely new system and
just be ready for it so Jesse and I show
up we do our sound check in the tent
you know completely different sound it
feels completely different but
readjusted pretty quickly
and so I was like okay and I was like I
hate the fact that people are going to
there's going to be people who can't see
because there's only so many people that
can fit in here and we've got these TVs
and we do what we could in a very shout
out to the mythical team and also Gary
and Matt who you know produced the the
show from an acoustic standpoint and
beyond that and and you know basically
just made the technical aspects of the
live events happen
um
very quick adjustments
so
but that was unfortunate because people
did have to stand and some people
couldn't see and it just wasn't planned
it how we wanted to it was a it was an
audible the energy was great though
because everybody was so jammed in there
and like at the beginning of your set
from my perspective I was like you know
we kind of had to
hide like I was literally looking
through a a crack in the tent watching
your set and then later on they allow
they found a space for us to go up to
the front like be right next to the
stage which ended up working out but
like uh even from that vantage point of
like looking through a crack
um it was just it was electric oh the
the heat the body heat and smells that
were coming out of that tent I was like
man everybody's excited well especially
at the at the like the final part we can
talk about that next time so it was a
wonderful experience I mean I said it on
Twitter the next day one of the most
special nights of my life I completely
believe that the whole the whole thing
was special that performance because it
was being able to
sing these songs to a group of people
who you know I didn't know you never
know like how many of these people who
are mythical beasts are listening to the
songs
I don't I don't know but when I start
singing and they immediately start
singing along that's awesome and so I
was closing my eyes for for the pretty
much the whole time but you may have
noticed if you watched me perform for
two reasons number one because I was
trying to remember the lyrics Because
when you haven't performed these songs
live it's another part of your brain
that you have to turn on in order to
remember 11 songs in a row yeah chords
and lyrics and also try to stay on tune
and also try not to cry because I was
like uh if I really take in what's
happening right now and the way that
these people are being supported and it
God knows if I look at anybody on the
front row every time I kind of peek down
there people are Weeping I'm like so
when I if I did open my eyes I looked
above them like my dad taught me to do
in public speaking you got to look above
the crowd so you don't get distracted
um just the feedback from people in all
of our meet and greets by this point we
had already done one two and two hour
meet and greet right before you that was
before our welcome so it was kind of
cool to like because we couldn't walk
around it was kind of cool to have that
meet and greet and to hear from fans in
their first reactions and but then the
second meet and greet on the second day
is when people were able to talk to you
about the James and shame uh experience
and people just had so many heartwarming
moving things to say about
uh our deconstruction stories their
identification with it even if they
ended up in a different place yeah yeah
um they were they were grateful for it
and then the people who connected so
much with the music it's like your album
has become this
um in their own words like a like a
Lifeline a Lifeline like something they
can hold on to that's like they how now
they have the shared experience in music
that like a lot of couples were talking
about how they connect over this album
because it ex a lot of people are saying
how it expressed that things that they
couldn't put into words much less music
and I was really moved to just you know
to just to witness
everybody come up and say how much they
connected with that obviously it was
happening during the concert but like
the stuff they had to say afterward yeah
it was very so special and it was so
special for Jesse too I mean first of
all we we almost didn't perform kill a
man because it's so guitar driven and I
didn't want to sell it short by just
doing an acoustic version but we put an
acoustic version together
I'm so glad we did it because it was the
highlight of the concert because Jesse
you know which a lot of people didn't
know that she's the one singing the
Opera on that part of killer man yeah
and she did it
and the Jaws were dropping she brought
the house down yeah it's great the the
the the the length of Applause when she
was done with it I was like I don't know
how long this is going to go on oh yeah
she felt so good it was such a good
experience for her so much you know
where she was like okay I feel like if
we have to do that again I can think
about it in a way that actually I can
anticipate it in a positive way
um I will take this just to quickly move
on from James on the shame I do want to
say because I don't want to forget about
it I announced it at mythicon and I'm
gonna announce it right here
um that a lot of people asked about
having a physical album for human
overboard and so
that is on sale right now
um we're gonna have a sort of a pre-sale
window I'm selling a record
and yes also a CD and a cassette because
people who are selling smaller
quantities of the CD and the cassette
but there was enough people who asked
about it
um so it's a pre-order you gotta like
say you got to make an order and then
that way you know how many to make yeah
and you know you're gonna have to be
patient obviously because vinyl
production is very slow right now but
there's a pre-order window we've got a
really cool design we're kind of taking
and being inspired by the album art to
actually make a record that has this
cool like Color Splash you know we're
not just doing a black record it's this
blue and green sort of tie-dye color mix
thing that's happening on the on the
record uh really nice interior sleeve
with lyrics and then the CD is probably
going to have this like poster fold
inside with this we've got lyrics on it
and that kind of thing
um and also there's some exclusive merch
that's being you can bundle with it or
you can get it just kind of as part of
the human overboard physical album
um got a a t-shirt that has like a cool
blue green kind of tie-dye pattern
that's coming off of like the ocean
inspiration from the album cover and
even a sweatshirt with a with with
lyrics from give a damn on it so you can
bundle that together you can get them
individually again James and the
shame.com this stuff's not going to be
available for a long so and also the
first uh few hundred or so copies of the
record that I sell I'm gonna have a
signed
exclusive postcard that goes inside
those so it comes with it comes with a
signature as well so jamesontheshame.com
appreciate your support you know we were
well taken care of uh in terms of
planning you know even when it comes to
like security that was a big unknown was
like
when you when you hire an event
production company to work on something
they don't know our fans and it's like
okay as part of this you got to have
security detail you got to make sure
that you know for any event you want you
want everybody attending to feel safe
and then also as like Talent on this
thing they wanted us to feel safe so
like we there was security that were
assigned to different things including
us and you know what I'll say
the mythical beasts were like super
chill it was it was like it felt in a
lot of ways like
a family reunion for like you know it's
just like some people wanted pictures a
lot of people just wanted to give a
friendly hello you know if they happen
to see crew the crew had great
experience in interacting with fans and
um so I you know credit to mythical
beasts and how
um
grounded they were like so many people
came up and we've heard this before when
we do when we tour
people the venues are like you how your
fans so cooperative and they don't cause
trouble and they're not Rowdy and they
don't they're not rude that was what
everybody at Star Hill was saying they
were talking about they were like they
don't litter and when somebody like they
were telling a story uh there was a time
when somebody took a trash can out of a
trash a trash bag out of a trash can in
order to throw it away and there's that
moment where you don't have a trash bag
in there yeah
and like one of the fans came up to
somebody who worked there and said we
need to get a bag in here so people you
know so it I love that that I didn't
have their own bag that's the community
that's the case that we together have
cultivated is a group of good people but
I love it I will I do have to share this
one story
I mean there's an exception to every
Rule and
um
I didn't tell you ahead of time but I'm
I'm just going to share it doesn't
matter
um so the security that we had was uh
they were
yeah they were taking care of us so I
you know I felt safe but like
Christy told me at a certain point that
like as she was
um I think it was the James and Shane
concert because they got a place
they were ushered to a place like
um
Christy and the kids Behind The Sound
area
and then there was somebody who was
making her pretty uncomfortable because
they just kept staring at her and like
and then she would look over her
shoulder and this this guy was staring
at her and then
um
she started looking more often and I was
like well you probably thought you were
interested she was like
every time I look back he was closer
and she said he had like Shifty eyes
kind of like looking at her and looking
around and so then she called didn't
seem to be enjoying himself uh-uh and
then so she but she did the right thing
and she got someone to contact security
and reported this guy and said okay
um there's somebody here is making me
really uncomfortable he's staring at me
he's not happy he's getting closer
um
um and the security said we'll we'll get
right on it and then
um
the guy who was staring at her turned
out to be the head of security
this is such a Christy story
it's like we're gonna call we're going
to call the head of security right now
and then all of a sudden a person that
staring at Christie's answering the
phone he's like yeah I got I got you and
I would I wonder how that was it was
just like what could you describe him
well he's got on a black jacket he's uh
he's got an earpiece he's got he's
bearded
uh with gray hair
khakis
she turned in the head as she's
currently talking on the phone
yeah and well and they were great she
just I mean I I'm like clueless I'm like
oh yeah like there's there's eight
security and again not that the mythical
beasts are to be worried about but again
it's this just it's standard protocol
you want to make sure that that right
everybody for mythical and everybody in
our family is is protected from somebody
who might want to do something so I
think that and we didn't get they were
great yeah they were great we didn't get
to see everything like all the stuff
that all the other podcasts that went on
like we could hear it from the stage and
then like all the mythical kitchen like
baby food eating contest I saw Josh in a
diaper beforehand and I saw that he
still had his belt afterward but we
didn't get to see a lot of people but um
yeah everything that we did get to
experience vicariously through fans and
as they talk to us in the meet and
greets or the stuff that we would see
every now and again and all the stuff
that we participated in it was just it
was still a very fulfilling experience
for us like getting up there the next
day my dad and I did a live dispatches
and I was just
just grinning from ear to ear watching
him take in all this fan adulation for
the first time it was so special like
just watching his experience the whole
time it was like it was like bringing
your kid to Disneyland for the first
time and everybody knew your kid at
Disneyland it's like that's what it felt
but it goes a Step Beyond that because
it's as if your dad has been preparing
for this moment his entire life he
didn't seem nervous and it's not just
that he doesn't seem nervous and you
know because people he was like finally
people in entertainment get their
parents involved for different reasons
because your parents tend to be
entertaining not necessarily as
entertaining as your dad uh but he's not
just this willing participant he's he's
more than that he's eager he's loving
every minute of it and the other thing
that he he's done which he did
multiple times
but especially at the end when we were
with the crew after the brunch and the
crew basically this was like a signing
off of mythicon yeah and it's just the
mythical crew Hood work mythicon kind of
together in a room
he did this several times but he did it
there as well he he's like this is my
opportunity to say something and so it
gets everybody's attention and it says
this really sweet thing about how
welcome he feels and and I looked at
Nancy and lancey's tearing up as he's
talking
Nancy his wife uh your stepmother is
what she is I know yeah consider of that
but that's what she is technically yeah
they just had the best time they kept
talking about the fans the people that
they were meeting because you have an
idea as a parent you have an idea of
what it is that your child does but not
really not really right and you can talk
about it you can be like yeah it's like
there are these people who I've
identified with the things that we and
our company
have put out into the world and they
really identify with it to the point
that they call themselves mythical
beasts and they will come to an event
like this but in little you see it and
you interact with these folks you don't
really appreciate it I think it was
Dawning on him repeatedly that this is I
didn't understand the level
of
just commitment
and the nature of the experience and of
course it's cool to see you know and we
we gave him a special role
arguably let's talk about let's talk
about the main show so the main show
um
I'm glad we were able to stream it and
then we're able to do video on demand
you know it's no longer available but
like there were opportunities for people
to experience it who weren't there and
I'm so glad because
it was
the most fun I've ever had on a stage of
ours I think I think it was our most fun
show we've ever done oh yeah like from a
personal standpoint my experience like
it everything that we've learned in our
couple of years of touring and doing
like three different stage shows we've
done like very technical
um like a polished presentation and then
with our last and then we did a bleak
Creek thing which was like more intimate
and totally different but then like the
Rhett and Link tour where it was just
like music and banter is where we really
started to learn that
the looser the better you know a lot of
what we're learning just with like a
mythical morning and Good Mythical More
in general is that
putting ourselves in environments where
we can be ourselves and interact with
each other and interact with people
is where we do our best work right and
just surprise each other and it's not
about hitting marks or certain lines
however that all being said there were
some very important marks to be hit yeah
you know because the show consisted of I
think five musical performances from
everything from you know starting out by
coming in on the double bike and doing
the I'm on vacation to a few acoustic
performances to closing it out with a
black light glow-in-the-dark Recreation
of our so dang dark video that was super
fun to put together
intermingled or intermixed with
something we've never done before which
is bringing a segment of GMM live on
stage in the international dart game
when when we we sang the where in the
world do these mythical beasts come from
and then the doors open and Chase the
Cartographer came out with that map like
like five times as big as the normal map
they went crazy for Chase like I was so
happy for Chase that like he had such a
moment you know oh yeah it was it was
wonderful and and then Stevie was on the
mic yeah so we'll talk about the the
alien part but my point was is that
there were a lot of marks to hit and
there were a lot of technical things to
do correctly yeah that you know when we
did our tour of mythicality show a few
years ago there was a two-week rehearsal
where we like rented out a rehearsal
space in Burbank and we like literally
two weeks of going there
on and off over the course of two weeks
getting all the marks down so you can
take this show and take it on the road
this was two hours of a rehearsal on
Thursday night to be ready for the show
now we knew what we were going to do and
we had scripted it out the descript the
parts that were you know outlined it's
not scripted
but you know when your dad showed up at
mythicon he didn't know he was going to
be an alien no I know I didn't tell him
I was like I'll find the right time to
tell him and which would end up being
perfect which was at dinner in front of
everybody
but what we knew he wanted to do was we
of course we had this idea and he would
he didn't bat an eye oh no and now I and
I didn't think he would but like now
knowing the way he interacts with these
ideas it's like we could get him to do
anything oh yeah but we knew he was very
dangerous we wanted to play around with
this idea that is a is an idea that some
people believe in I don't uh personally
necessarily believe in it but this idea
that you can connect with aliens through
meditation we're like oh that's a fun uh
sort of foil to do this set where we can
kind of do some improv music where we're
like helping the alien zero in now I'll
just go ahead and say if you were
watching on the live stream
uh and you felt like that segment just
went on too long well it wasn't really
it wasn't primarily for you it was it
the show was primarily for the people
who were there right who were
participating in that chant who were
looking to the skies and we said listen
this is primarily for the people who
showed up the mythicon but we're gonna
offer it as a live stream because if you
want to feel like you're part of it you
can but I can imagine that moment of
like you know group meditation that's
not something people like stream on the
internet for like thousands of views and
I'm sure people who were there thought
it was going on for a long time but
again what's your hobby I like to watch
other people meditate we were doing
again none of that was written the only
thing that was pre-written were the
coordinates that Jenna had found of the
exact spot that we were at starhilled
and they were they were on my Shruti box
taped on my Shruti box that's where I
was reading my shootie box I was playing
it which is why when when that person
and we both retweeted the thing like
uh leading up to Mythic on somebody
tweeted that video of this like hippie
looking dude playing this instrument and
then another dude blowing bubbles on
stage and I was like this is basically
our ver we've already planned our
version we're already ready for it and
so like I love the fact that somebody
said this is going to be rent Link in X
number of years I'm like no this is
going to be written Link in X number of
weeks yeah yeah just get ready for it so
it was so weird and we were like yeah I
set it up like listen you're here
you're you're up for anything so we just
want to take full advantage of that so
now we are going to contact aliens and
then everybody was up for it oh they
were so up for it now
it was so when we originally
conceptualized this it was just hey
we're gonna do this thing of we're
trying to contact aliens obviously it's
gonna fail but then it's going to result
in Charles an alien showing up
now we wanted it to be something where
we might be able to fool some people or
give you the the emotional feeling of
that you have made contact and so the
first thing we looked into was like a
drone show
those are it's when you have that's when
you have like if you don't know like
could be 20 or 30 or hundreds of drones
that are programmed to like make a giant
face in the sky they did it if you look
up drone show uh it's Burning Man
awesome there's a giant face I mean it's
like the face of God looking down at you
if you're so crazy now we already
indicated earlier that we did not make
any money
so we weren't about to spend the like
approximately one million dollars that
would have cost in order to if you get
one of these companies to do the type of
drone show that they do for like the NBA
finals or something so we quickly
downgraded to One Singular drone that we
rented
but and you may think oh okay but if you
were there and we and and I if you were
really close if you were like on the
front row the stage is actually too big
for you to see it but so you needed to
be back kind of in the middle than
everybody in the back I went back there
uh during the rehearsal in Washington I
was like oh gosh this is going to be
great yeah Ben rented a drone he piloted
the Drone it had a big Spotlight on it
so it was very it's like a it was like a
search search and rescue drone Spotlight
yeah well and apparently it was so
convincing that when we were doing our
brunch the next morning on Sunday
morning
we were saying like hey what was your
highlight a lot of people said the show
last night just absolutely loved it
and then one person piped up and said do
you guys know that right when you were
doing that thing where you contacted
aliens
a plane flew over really really low
it freaked me out I thought maybe
something we had done had worked we were
like really you sure you you sure it
wasn't a UFO that then landed behind the
stage right so the way it happened was
is that we're singing the coordinates
chanting the coordinates then chanting
we are looking to the skies for you at
which point Ben kind of brings the drone
over the stage and then slowly lowers it
down behind the stage and this is all
choreographed with this sound design
that Ben has put together including this
really low if you again this is one of
those things that like while being there
was so much different because they
started playing this very low Rumble
that was shaking the entire place as
this drone is coming down right and yeah
then when it lands there's this it feels
like a
the like this light comes on from behind
the stage and then you know it took a
while to kind of get things situated we
were kind of waiting there for a while
but eventually the doors open CO2
cannons boom light and then an alien
with a giant freaking head like an eight
foot tall alien with four arms is
standing there with a three ring binder
and
yeah the alien comes out and just kind
of like shuffles forward
he lifts his forearms with the tablet in
his left hand
he says spider a binder
greetings earthlings I come in peace I
come in peace I don't think Dad changed
his voice at all I'd say like a 10 chain
but this is where your dad being your
dad really
made this segment
and and I think the best way to
illustrate what it's like to work with
your dad in this context is to talk
about the rehearsal
we had a little discussion with him and
it was essentially Charles you know the
doors are going to open you're going to
come out you're going to say Greetings
that come in peace
um then we're gonna have a little
discussion with you about where do you
come from what your what's your name
and then you're going to say that I
brought you a gift it's the time gate
and then this big sort of elevator
looking thing is going to kind of come
out from the door and then you're gonna
there's an instruction manual that
you're gonna read it's a three-ring
binder that explains basically why
you're giving us to this and what we can
do and it sets up the next bit you don't
have to memorize how the time gate works
you just read it off the manual in the
first so during the rehearsal he walks
out
he spreads his arms and he says welcome
Earthlings
as if as if we're all the ones that
showed up welcome to this planet I just
arrived at that you're already on yeah I
was like oh okay A little twist there I
got a choice a little twist and we told
him that when we ask him what his name
is that his name is Daryl in our
language
well we said so then we have too
difficult for you to understand it in my
language but it's the equivalent of
Daryl it's what we told him yeah yeah
and so then when we're doing the
rehearsal I'm like well what's your name
and he's like
Charles which I was like that's perfect
like yeah so he got it all right during
the show
unfortunately well because you kept
telling me to like to help him out to
like make sure you have the right lines
which he did well that was I think it
would have been even funnier that
actually wasn't that he he wasn't
supposed to say that his name was Daryl
he was supposed to say that
I can't pronounce my name I know but he
just said Daryl he did it ended up
getting a laugh but the funniest part of
the rehearsal was when we said did you
bring a gift and he holds up the binder
and he's like I brought this book
this and it was the gift is the book
we're like no no no no no the gift is
the time gate and that's just book
instruction manual that was it that was
uh and it seemed like it was difficult
to
um for him to get to restore that
information in his buddy buddy but he
did the he did by the time we got around
to the show
I'm just glad you didn't trip and fall
you know like bust his brain open and
I'm talking about that huge alien brain
that was like his whole face was in the
mouth of the alien that's so funny I was
so proud of him he did awesome he loved
every second of it it was great and uh
and then Jordan you know was in the time
of course the bit was you can
communicate with your past selves your
present selves or your future selves and
so we kind of brought in
what Jordan has really done a good job
with on GMM which is
putting his mouth up to a hole saying
some insane and so he played young me
and young you and then old me and old
you yeah but we each played present us
and then whatever the other the other
one it was fun it was it was it was a
good ending I mean
that was fun that was a nice bit and
then we like sang lonely sad little
water dispensing tab did a little
sing-along and then we went away we put
on our suits and we did the The Encore
did uh so dang dark I almost stepped off
of the stage I will say that because we
during The Encore we had to go back and
change and again these would have been
bad there are these little things that
you work out in a
doing a rehearsal even a second
rehearsal that we just didn't it was we
didn't have time because we got there
and here's the stage and this all the
stuff's coming together this stuff has
just been built just in time
so when we go back to change out of our
clothes into the skin tight
clothes that have black light reflective
paint on them that mimics exactly the
way we looked in the sodang dark video
there were no lights and so there were
steps down to this area that we were
going to change and I kind of knew that
there were steps there and I didn't know
that there were like
they were kind of not that wide and so
when I stepped down I stepped completely
down to the next level and I mean that
could have been catastrophic but I just
happened I could have broken your hip I
caught myself and
that was the only moment that I felt
unsure nobody left on a stretcher no
excited us success
and I'll you know after that was the
was my DJ set to close things out so
which which we'll talk about next
episode but
and then the next morning yeah we had a
brunch with like people who had that
ticket and like like you said we went
around and talked to a bunch of mythical
beasts as they were eating wedding
receptions and also the the mythical
crew was there for that our wives were
there for that really the first time
that uh Jesse and Christy have
interacted with mythical beasts in that
way I think yeah yeah
and you know the fact that you know Lily
and Lincoln Orlando were also there was
very special to me I know lot couldn't
make it because he was you know just
getting going with school but Shepard
was there and I'm just so glad that they
were there as a big part of it like Lily
posted a picture of like me getting
ready for my DJ set but we're like
hanging out on this bed like in one of
the places the day before it's just like
you know these are all this like great
memories for me that the moment I took
that initial tour and walked around
right when we arrived I was like I'm so
glad that my family's showing up for
this thing and experiencing this because
you know whatever we do next will be
different you know it that's how we are
so it'll be enough the same but enough
different to still be exciting but to be
the first one for it to be so special
you know special for everybody who was
there and to have like our family there
to have so many of the mythical crew
there
um and that they had good experiences it
was it all just
you know it was high stress and um
people had to work them their themselves
to the Bone
I acknowledge that but like
and it it in my opinion it was all worth
it you know from my perspective I'm just
so proud of what everybody did to put
into it and then we got it to experience
it uh
together it was just yeah it was awesome
it was it was it was absolutely
a career highlight for me oh yeah yes
thank you to everybody who was able to
make it we know that you know in the
scheme of things it was a relatively
small percentage of of mythical beasts
but you know many of you who are some of
our most active mythical beasts who you
know make their their
their passion for all things mythical
known on the internet on a regular basis
a lot of you were there people that
we've met before previous tours and meet
and greets uh and a lot of people we
haven't met before
obviously we couldn't do this without
you and you made it a very very special
thing that we're going to take
everything that we learned and all the
the things that made it really special
made it unique all the all the best
parts of it and try to find ways to
replicate that moving forward what
that's going to look like like you said
we don't know
but
we always love to start something learn
from it keep moving forward and
there's nothing like
there's nothing like when we all get
together like that
we say every time we tour
yeah but it's just it remains true that
there's nothing like being in the same
place with a bunch of mythical beasts
especially after everything that like
you know with the pandemic of it all you
know it's really it it it gave us a
renewed appreciation
for being there and the bit if you have
any ability
to create something have people show up
and collaboratively make it an
experience yeah you know so very
grateful
um I feel like we took our own advice we
stopped we celebrated
we're gonna do more of that in the next
episode to kind of oh yeah speaking of
pretty up you said you want to know my
perspective I have
I have a lot of thoughts about uh
you're you you uh the birth of Elkhound
snuggle baby
um
but do you have a wreck today I do it's
just the same thing I've already talked
about which is the physical album oh
human overview just more self-promotion
yeah right I just want to make that's
not what wrecks are for that doesn't
count
I thought that was against the right I
think in this case it does yeah James oh
you know what I'm glad I talked about it
because
if you go to jamesonthesham.com or you
just go to any one of my social media
profiles and click on the link tree
there
you can join the mailing list look at
you in your mailing list uh you know if
you hey musicians man Gotta Have mailing
lists I don't know why but they do
um you can get a discount code that you
can apply to the album oh that's
something I forgot so that's that's
worth mentioning so if you want to get
um I think we're doing a 10 discount
code
join the mailing list I'm not going to
send very many emails trust me because
I'm not doing a whole lot that needs
that needs email sent but if so when
there is something special that you need
to know about like a physical product or
a discount or a
whatever you can join the mailing list
but mainly to get that discount okay I
get it James and the shame.com
we'll holla at you next week let us know
what you think hashtag earbiscuits and
of course you can always respond to
anything that we've talked about give us
your take on it 1-88
earpod one for the voicemail hi my name
is Victoria I'm a nurse from Ontario
Canada and I just wanted
you guys know that most pills are both
soluble and chewable but a large
majority aren't especially those that
are extended release so if you have
questions please speak to your
pharmacist before chewing any old random
pill thanks hi Rhett and Link I'm into
mythicon this year and it was very cool
to see Jenna and all like the women that
you guys have on um your crew and your
team my work in production you know is
very like rarely has women on like set
in Productions and I just wanted to make
a note of how rare it feels that's all I
wanted to say like y'all are wonderful
um and you surrounded yourself with such
wonderful people and you seem to have
like a really awesome eye for that so
love y'all hi rotten link this is Jade
from Claremore Oklahoma and I'm just
curious how you came up with the name
L count snuggle baby
love it hey written link this is Mallory
from Boston and a friend of mine
actually turned me on to you guys during
the pandemic and I am forever grateful
to that friend um I was listening to
your episode from mythicon which was a
plus by the way and I really liked what
you guys had to say about friendship so
I thought I'd provide a wreck of my own
since you guys are always providing such
great wrecks to all of us and it's a
book called Big friendship and it's by
aminatuso check it out to watch more ear
biscuits click on the playlist on the
right to watch the previous episode of
your biscuits click on the playlist to
the left and don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe if you
prefer to listen to this podcast it's
available on all your favorite podcast
platforms thanks for being your mythical
best
foreign
[Music]